[Music]
it's one-man show you're gonna talk as
you said about a lot of personal stuff
very famously in the 1980s you were
married to Robin Givens and you are
gonna talk about the fact and this is
something I did not know that after your
divorce you guys were still somewhat
involved well no we would just you know
me yeah
during our crazy married right we you
know I'm saying yeah Steve you're gold
thing and you know beauty you beat me up
I don't know I was a young kid and I I
miss my wife even after you were
divorced you would sometimes go over to
her house that's okay that's fine that's
your now you tell a story about what
used to drive over there at night and oh
no this is the morning wrong you know
and I go to the house I ring the buzzer
no one's there I go back to my car
okay they might be working and if I go
to my car she drives up all right it's
what happened it's going down she drives
up with the handsome Brad Pitt oh man go
get No
[Applause]
Brad Pitt is the international symbol
for that yeah I think Brad Pitt sees you
he's got a he's got to be scared
cuz she's going up with your ex-wife at
her house and you're sitting there in a
car I was just um emotionally comatose
good I went for my heart there I went
for my heart's down into a wet noodle
and it said Toby over here talking I had
no energy to fight or anything I finally
a story I can relate to
[Applause]